What if the thing that makes you feel different is actually the thing that makes you a better psychologist? Today I'm joined by Dr. Sunil Ladd, a consultant counselling psychologist, national NHS clinical director, someone who's spent over 20 years working in prison and mental health settings, he also happens to be 3 foot 11 inches tall. And in this episode, we're not just talking about height. We're talking about identity, labels, power, different. and what happens when you grow up in a body the world wasn't built for. Because here's the deeper question, how do you turn lived experience of being othered into leadership and beyond?
如果让你感到与众不同的地方，恰恰正是让你成为一名更优秀的心理学家的原因呢？今天，咨询心理学家、英国国民 NHS 临床主任孙尼尔·拉德（Dr. Sunil Ladd）博士做客我们的节目。他有20多年在监狱和心理健康领域工作的经验，而他恰好身高只有 3 英尺 11 英寸（约 1.2 米）。在这一集里，我们不仅要谈论身高。我们还要谈论身份、标签、权力、“不同”，以及当你在一个不为你这样身材的世界中长大时会发生什么。因为这里有一个更深层次的问题：如何将自己作为“局外人”的生活经历转化为领导力及更多可能？
If you've ever felt different, wondered whether this career is for someone like you, or if you're curious how compassion, therapy, and even yoga can transform suffering into strength, then this conversation might just change how you see yourself. If you find it helpful, I'd love it. Comment, liked and subscribe for more. Hi, I just wanted to welcome along our guest for today. Dr. Sunil Lad, who is a consultant counselling psychologist. Hi, Sunil. Hi, Marianne. Really good to be here with you today.
如果你曾感到与众不同，怀疑这份职业是否适合像你这样的人，或者你很好奇同情心、治疗甚至瑜伽如何将痛苦转化为力量，那么这段对话可能会改变你看待自己的方式。如果你觉得这有帮助，我将不胜感激。请评论、点赞并订阅以获取更多内容。嗨，我只想欢迎我们今天的嘉宾。孙尼尔·拉德博士，他是一位咨询心理学家。嗨，孙尼尔。嗨，玛丽安。很高兴今天能和你在一起。
Lovely to have you here. And thank you for connecting with me on LinkedIn. And I know we've had some quite interesting conversations and there's a variety of ideas we had for episodes. And we're actually going to be doing two episodes together. So if people find what we're talking about useful, please do check out our next episode two. Could I ask you for anyone who's not watching on YouTube
很高兴你能来。谢谢你在领英（LinkedIn）上与我建立联系。我知道我们曾有过一些非常有趣的对话，对于这几期节目我们也有各种各样的想法。我们实际上会一起录制两期节目。因此，如果大家觉得我们讨论的内容有用，请务必收看我们的第二集。我想请问你，对于那些没有在 YouTube 上观看的人
or who might be visually impaired or just wants to understand the way that you see yourself and your body? Could you please describe a little bit about yourself, Sunil? Yeah, sure. So I guess what I'd say is that, you know, people would probably class me as having a disability. So I'm 3, 4.11 in height. But yeah, so some of my limbs are a bit shorter than other.
或者可能有视力障碍，或者只是想了解你看待自己和身体的方式的人，孙尼尔，你能稍微描述一下你自己吗？好的，没问题。我想我会说，人们可能会认为我有残疾。所以我的身高是 3 英尺 11 英寸。不过是的，我的一些四肢比别人短一些。
So obviously that has led to some challenges I've faced throughout my life over time. Thank you. And I'm aware that there's all sorts of terms that have been used in the past that maybe aren't always that inclusive or kind of very positive or kind of affirming for the person themselves. I know before we started recording, I was talking about a lovely book that my sons and I have read, which is by an author called Chinade Burke, and it's called Breaking the Mold. And she, I think, is about three and a half foot tall. And she really didn't like some of the labels that had been kind of leveled at her when she was growing up. So she actually, I think, petitioned the Irish government to have the term little person added to the deal.
所以显这然给我在生活中随着时间推移带来了一些挑战。谢谢。我意识到过去使用过各种各样的术语，这些术语可能并不总是那么具有包容性，或者对当事人来说不是非常积极或肯定。我知道在开始录制之前，我谈到过一本我和儿子们读过的可爱的书，作者叫奇纳德·伯克（Chinade Burke），书名叫《打破常规》（Breaking the Mold）。我想她身高大约三英尺半。她非常不喜欢自己在成长过程中被贴上的某些标签。所以我想她曾向爱尔兰政府请愿，要求将“小个子”（little person）一词加入
dictionary and that's what she likes to use as describing herself. But I'm aware that everybody is unique and should be able to kind of think about what sits right for them. Could I ask you what you think about, about names, about labels, about kind of how you prefer to think and talk about yourself if that's okay? Yeah, sure. No, thanks, Marianne. That's a really good question. And I think we use these all sorts of labels in order to kind of describe ourselves and sometimes that can be quite limiting and I think it's really important we think about what's quite freeing. So I guess you know what I would kind of for myself look at is being a short person
字典里，这就是她喜欢用来描述自己的词。但我知道每个人都是独一无二的，应该能够考虑什么才真正适合自己。如果可以的话，我想问问你对名字、标签以及你倾向于如何思考和谈论自己的看法？好的，没问题。谢谢你，玛丽安。这是一个非常好的问题。我认为我们使用各种各样的标签来描述自己，有时这可能是相当局限的，我认为思考什么是真正解放的东西非常重要。所以我想我对自己而言，会看作是一个个子矮的人
because I think for me that feels like it's a it's a statement of fact really. I think it's hard isn't it because sometimes we put all sorts of judgments to different words. So yeah I think I prefer that really. Thank you and today we're kind of thinking about people's experiences, obviously heavily informed by your own experiences, but generically when we're working with people clinically, obviously people can come up against different challenges because of the body they find themselves to be in. But of course, you know, when we're working with people, maybe we might be looking at a mother's experience of raising a child who's growing
因为我认为对这我来说感觉就像是一个事实陈述。这很难，不是吗？因为有时我们会对不同的词汇赋予各种各样的判断。所以是的，我想我更喜欢这种说法。谢谢。今天我们主要讨论人们的经历，这显然在很大程度上受到你自身经历的启发，但一般来说，当我们从事临床工作时，人们显然会因为自己所处的身体而面临不同的挑战。但当然，当我们与人合作时，我们可能会关注母亲抚养一个在
up in a different body or a father or for that amount of siblings. It can be really difficult when you feel like you're getting very different treatment to your siblings, because we might like to think that we exist in isolation, but that isn't the case. Could I ask you for a little bit about kind of your experiences of growing up in a different body, So now? Yes. So I think for me, it's kind of thinking about the environment in which I've grown up in, really. So, yeah, so I guess there were people in my family, so my sister, my dad, with the same condition, whereas my mum wasn't,
不同身体中长大的孩子的经历，或者父亲的经历，亦或是兄弟姐妹的经历。当你觉得你受到的对待与你的兄弟姐妹非常不同时，这可能会非常困难，因为我们可能倾向于认为我们是孤立存在的，但事实并非如此。孙尼尔，能跟我们分享一些你在一个与众不同的身体中长大的经历吗？好的。所以我想对我来说，这实际上是关于思考我所生长的环境。所以，是的，我想我的家庭里有人，比如我姐姐、我爸爸，都有同样的状况，而我妈妈则没有，
and then a larger extended family where there were other people without the condition as well. So I think it's interesting, isn't it? And I think especially growing up, we develop all sorts of insecurities. And I guess that sometimes can be hidden or that can be seen by others, but also I guess when we're growing up,
还有一个更大的扩展家庭，里面也有其他人没有这种状况。所以我觉得这很有趣，不是吗？而且我认为特别是在成长过程中，我们会产生各种各样的不安全感。我想有时这可能会被隐藏起来，或者会被别人看到，但我也认为当我们成长时，
we're often compared to others around us as well, aren't we? whether that's how clever you are or how tall you are. You know, we're often seen to have either unattractive or attractive qualities where people, the environment kind of really promotes us. So I guess, you know, everyone will have their unique journey of what that looks like and then people develop their own coping strategies to cope with that, whether that's deciding, you know, I think a lot of therapy for me
我们经常会与周围的人进行比较，不是吗？无论是关于你有多聪明还是你有多高。我们经常被视为具有不吸引人的特质或有吸引力的特质，周围的环境真的在强化这些。所以我想，每个人都会有属于自己独一无二的旅程，展现出不同的面貌，然后人们会发展出自己的应对策略来应付这些，无论是决定——我觉得对我来说，很多的治疗
has kind of made me realize that actually that's why I got quite academic and I got quite motivated in order to compensate about feeling different in a way or feeling not good enough, deciding to use, yeah, getting qualifications or working hard as a psychologist or wanting to be a psychologist to kind of compensate against that really. Yeah, absolutely. And as you're speaking, I'm thinking about a lot of the identities I might see myself as and the labels that are I've either kind of given to myself or others have given to me over the years. And, you know, I think it's always very difficult when you're going from becoming a teenager to a young adult and beyond. And, you know, you might want to be, I want to do this, I want to live independently.
让我意识到，实际上这就是为什么我变得很有学术追求，而且很有动力，以此来某种程度上弥补那种感到与众不同或觉得自己不够好的感觉，决定去利用——是的，通过获得资格证书，或者作为一名心理学家努力工作，或者渴望成为一名心理学家，来真正弥补这一点。是的，绝对是这样。当你在说话时，我想到了我可能会看到的自己的许多身份，以及这些年来我给自己贴上的或者别人给我贴上的标签。而且，你知道，我认为从青少年过渡到年轻成人及以后的过程总是非常困难的，你知道，你可能想要，我想做这个，我想独立生活。
But I would think maybe with being of smaller stature, maybe people are more likely to infantilise you or speak down to you or treat you differently. Has that been your experience? I think it's been really interesting in terms of especially, definitely, definitely, has been my experience and I think it's really interesting to see the different spheres in which I travel and I especially when I do training I kind of talk about the difference and recognizing the difference of for example how people might see me just as I'm shopping in Sainsbrutes compared to when I'm in a meeting as the lead psychologist in the whole team for example or you know walking into prisons with my role so
但我认为，也许由于身材较小，人们可能更有可能将你婴儿化（把你看作小孩）、对你说话居高临下或者对你区别对待。这就是你的经历吗？我觉得特别是在——这绝对、绝对是我的经历，而且我觉得很有趣的一点是，看到我所经历的不同领域，尤其是当我做培训时，我会谈论并识别这种差异，例如，当我在塞恩斯伯里超市（Sainsbury's）购物时人们如何看我，与我在整个团队中作为首席心理学家开会时，或者，你知道，带着我的角色走进监狱时，人们如何看我。
So I think there is something about, again, how do we use different labels or, you know, what do people initially see, which means that they might get treated as less than? Because I think automatically you do get that. But I think there's also something about how you might carry yourself as well, you know, I think for me, even just going to Sainsbury's, for example, and try not to hold any shame when I've got to ask for something that's on a high shelf. whereas actually that was a journey in itself, I think for me, kind of feeling really embarrassed at first to ask someone. And I think that that takes a bit of time. And I think maybe that's why I also trained as a psychologist to learn these skills of why I help other people as well.
所以我觉得这里面有些东西，再次体现了我们如何使用不同的标签，或者人们最初看到的是什么，这可能导致他们被当作低人一等来对待？因为我认为你自然会得到这种对待。但我也认为，这里面还有关于你如何举止得体的问题，你知道，对我和我来说，哪怕只是去塞恩斯伯里超市购物，当必须请求别人帮忙拿高货架上的东西时，也努力不带有任何羞耻感。而实际上这本身就是一个过程，对我来说，起初向别人开口会感到非常尴尬。我想这需要一点时间。我想这也是为什么我也受训成为一名心理学家，去学习这些技能，以便我也能帮助其他人。
But I think it's important to think about actually, yes, the world might not be equipped. but at the same time, I think, you know, as I'm someone who practice compassion-focused therapy, one of the things that I often think about is where is the wisdom? What wisdom can I use to apply to kind of really look at this rather than getting caught up in suffering? But I guess in a way, probably a lot of those experiences throughout my life have led to suffering in a way, you know, being talked down to. But also, I think maybe things are changing. I think people are really aware of these things now. People are, yeah, more conscious to not be disrespectful in a way
但我认为重要的是要考虑，是的，世界可能没有做好准备。但与此同时，我认为，作为一个践行以同情为焦点的疗法（compassion-focused therapy）的人，我经常思考的一个问题是：智慧在哪里？我能运用什么智慧来真正看待这个问题，而不是陷入痛苦之中？但我想在某种程度上，我一生中的许多经历可能在某种程度上导致了痛苦，你知道，被人居高临下地对待。但同时，我也认为情况可能正在改变。我认为人们现在对这些事情有了真正的认识。人们，是的，更有意识不去表现得不尊重，
compared to probably when I was growing up, whereas people would be quite, obviously, there's probably cultural and kind of intergenerational messages, whereas I think older people would be quite okay with making a joke, whereas younger people I think would probably be a lot more uncomfortable. about it as well. And I think there's something about one of the things I recognise is that actually sometimes people can feel really uncomfortable and that's when they decide to make some kind of joke because that's their way of trying to talk about it but not talk about it as well.
与我成长的时候相比，那时候人们会相当——显然可能存在文化和跨代的信息传递，老一代人可能会觉得开个玩笑完全没问题，而我认为年轻人可能会对此感到更加不舒服。而且关于这一点，我认识到的一点是，有时人们会感到非常不舒服，正因如此，他们才决定开某种玩笑，因为那是他们试图谈论它却又无法真正谈论它的一种方式。
Yeah, I think, you know, I often, I hope people are getting better and getting kinder, certainly in person, but keyboard warriors are not always that kind. and trolls. And I don't know if you follow the account of, it's a couple called, I think I called Squirmie and Grub. And one of them is in a wheelchair and I think has some sort of kind of muscle condition where the muscle tone is affected. But the female is kind of normal stature and walks ably. And people, I mean, that's their brand now. So I think that's what they do. They talk about campaigning and about kind of, yeah, how it's okay to, to be in a relationship and loving sexual relationship with someone that might look very different
是的，我认为，我常常——我希望人们在现实生活中能变得更好、更善良，但键盘侠并不总是那么善良，还有喷子。我不知道你是否关注一个账号，是一对情侣，我想他们叫“蠕动与肥胖”（Squirmie and Grub）。其中一个人坐轮椅，我想他患有某种影响肌肉张力的肌肉疾病。但女方身材正常，行动自如。人们——我的意思是，现在那是他们的品牌了。所以我想这就是他们所做的。他们谈论倡导活动，以及，是的，如何能够与一个看起来可能与你截然不同的人建立恋爱关系和充满爱意的性关系，
to you and that people will really struggle, I think, to see that that's a genuine relationship or that it might say something about her if she finds him sexually attractive and whether that's consensual, but also like, A, it's not your business. They're grown adults, but they are happy to kind of answer those questions and kind of, I guess, try to reduce that stigma but yeah I think hopefully in person people are kinder but yeah the keyboard warriors I think it's very tricky yeah I think we are living in a different different age in a way where I guess we probably might have we might be very clear on what people might think before because they'd just say it but maybe really clumsily maybe in a joke but it'd be said whereas this is
而人们会真的很难去看待这是一个真正的关系，或者如果她觉得他在性方面很有吸引力，这可能会说明她的一些问题，以及这是否是双方自愿的，但同时，就像，A，这不管你的事。他们是成年人，但他们很乐意回答这些问题，并且，我想，试图减少这种耻辱感。但是的，我认为希望在现实生活中人们更善良吧，不过，键盘侠嘛，我觉得这非常棘手。是的，我觉得我们生活在一个不同的时代，在某种程度上，我们可能非常清楚别人以前可能会怎么想，因为他们会直接说出来，虽然可能说得很笨拙，或者当作一个玩笑，但好歹说出来了。而现在，
you know, it's meaning that people are really venting some of their frustrations or just being really cruel as well. I think, you know, especially working in the prison system, I really recognise there is a dark side to humanity that we don't always want to talk about, or it gets used as entertainment in a way, or it gets played out in a certain way. And I think, you know, one of the things that I'm really conscious of, and especially thinking about this particular conversation is, you know, humour. I remember going to university and I used to love comedy nights, but also at the same time, really be really defensive and really ready for a joke to be had at my expense. And I think there is something about actually how comfortable our society with things.
这意味着人们真的在宣泄他们的一些挫败感，或者表现得非常残酷。我认为，特别是通过在监狱系统工作，我真正认识到人性中确实有黑暗的一面，这是我们并不总是想谈论的，或者它被当作一种娱乐方式，或者以某种方式上演。而且我认为，我非常清楚的一件事情，特别是在思考这次特定的对话时，就是幽默。我记得去上大学时，我曾非常喜欢喜剧之夜，但与此同时，我也非常具有防御性，随时准备好成为别人开玩笑的对象。而且，我们的社会对事物的适应程度确实存在某种现象。
How do we get primed into certain what is right or what is wrong? What should we feel comfortable about? What shouldn't we feel comfortable about? and what are no-go areas in a way. And I think in a way, what we probably need is a bit of a sense of, well, why do these keyboard warriors kind of happen? What's missing in their lives in a way, which means that they're letting out this level of anger and hatred towards others,
我们是如何被引导去认同什么是对的或什么是错的？我们应该对什么感到舒适？我们不应该对什么感到舒适？以及什么是绝对不能触碰的禁区。我想在某种程度上，我们可能需要有一种感觉，那就是，为什么这些键盘侠会出现？他们的生活中缺少了什么，以至于他们向别人释放出这种程度的愤怒和仇恨，
but obviously not able to do it in a small, they probably are in an aspect doing it within their own lives, but feeling that in a way they're able to do it more freely on the internet. And I think, again, I guess it goes back to that sense of anonymity as well. You know, if you think about some of the research of what we might do when we're in a car, for example, compared to when you're in person with someone. Actually, yeah, you might be more vocal when you're in a car compared to when you're face-to-face. Or even, you know, if we think about the new world of being online, actually how people,
但显然无法在小范围内做到——他们可能在某种程度上在自己的生活中这样做，但在互联网上却觉得自己能够更自由地这样做。而且我认为，这又回到了那种匿名感。你知道，如果你想想关于我们在车里时的行为与面对面时的行为的研究。实际上，是的，你在车里时可能会比面对面时更大声、更直言不讳。甚至，你知道，如果我们想想网上生活的新世界，人们在线下的表现与在线上的表现相比，确实存在差异。
people are in person compared to when they're online as well. Yeah, I think there's something about that. Yeah, absolutely. And I'm aware kind of people of shorter stature are often dissuaded or even are not allowed to apply for certain jobs. So one of my friends that I grew up with, I'm fairly sure, right in a sense, she was 4 foot 10, 4 foot 11, that sort of threshold. She'd always been really interested in travel and tourism and leisure and really, really wanted to be an air cabin person, stewardess.
是的，我觉得这其中有些门道。是的，绝对是这样。我意识到，身材较矮的人经常被劝阻，甚至不被允许申请某些工作。所以和我一起长大的一个朋友，我相当确信，对，某种意义上，她身高4英尺10英寸、4英尺11英寸，就在那个门槛上。她一直对旅游、观光和休闲非常感兴趣，并且非常、非常想成为一名飞机客舱乘务员、空姐。
She would have been amazing at it as well, just that she would have been incredible. She was never allowed to apply because she was too short. I think you had to be five foot four or something like that in your flat feet. And when I say flat feet, I mean with no heels on, really difficult. And, you know, you said that you've kind of worked. in prisons and justice systems are there any are there any kind of additional considerations or people saying actually you can't come in here you can't do that you've got to be of a certain height is that something you've come up against in your career senel or in your
她完全能胜任，简直难以置信，她会非常出色。但她从来不被允许申请，因为她太矮了。我想光脚要求身高达到5英尺4英寸左右。当我指光脚时，我的意思是没穿高跟鞋，这真的很难。而且，你说过你曾在监狱和司法系统中工作，是否还有任何——有没有任何额外的考虑，或者有人说“实际上你不能进来，你不能这样做，你必须达到一定的高度”，这是你在职业生涯中遇到过的情况吗，孙尼尔，或者在你的
history yeah actually i haven't and it's interesting you know i've worked in prisons for over 20 years now and i kind of fell into it in a way or maybe i didn't fall into it but it kind of happened and i don't think I was potentially aware of just what I was walking into, but I think at that time I obviously had a can-do attitude and had supportive people around me who said, well, actually we can make this work in a way. So it's never, I guess again, you know, there are things that might be high up or whatever. And I think actually when I first did start to walk into prisons, I think people were really worried. Would he be able to survive this type of environment, which which can be really hostile, would he be attacked, would his safety be, something to be concerned
经历中？是的，其实我没有遇到过。这很有趣，你知道，我在监狱工作已经20多年了，我算是误打误撞进去了，或者也许我不是误打误撞，但它就是发生了。而且我觉得我当时可能并没有意识到自己将要面对的是什么，但我想当时我显然有一种“我能行”的态度，周围也有支持我的人说：“其实我们可以让这行得通。”所以它从来没有——我想再次说明，有些东西可能会比较高，诸如此类。而且我想当我第一次走进监狱时，人们真的很担心：他能在这个可能充满敌意的环境中生存下来吗？他会被袭击吗？他的安全会成为一个令人担忧的问题吗？
about, but touch would, you know, over 20 years, I've even worked in high secure prisons. Nothing has ever happened back because I think there is that kind of general code in terms of actually, you know, therapeutically it's meant that people have felt able to be vulnerable with me in a way. So I think, yes, we think about the dark side of humanity, but also we can also think about the caring side of humanity as well. And I think, you know, there is, you know, I do look back and I think, oh gosh, you know, how did I navigate that? But there might be, for example, certain places which are harder for me to go through. But it's never, no one's ever said no in a way. There's always been that. Okay. So how do we make adjustments? And I guess for me,
但谢天谢地，你知道，在过去的20多年里，我甚至在高度安全的监狱里工作过。从来没有发生过任何坏事，因为我认为存在着一种普遍的准则，即从治疗的角度来看，这意味着人们觉得能够在我面前展现出脆弱的一面。所以，是的，我们考虑人性黑暗的一面，但我们也可以考虑人性关怀的一面。而且我认为，回过头来看，我会想：“天哪，我是怎么度过那段日子的？”但可能有些地方对我来说穿行起来更困难。然而从来没有人说过“不行”。总会有这样的情况：好吧，我们如何进行调整？我想对我来说，
that's probably the reality of my life in a way. How do I, how do I, adjust to the situation to something which isn't necessarily quick and easy to think about, really. So I think there is something about the resilience that we develop as human beings once we start to have that sense of adjustment. Yeah, absolutely. And I think one of the really lovely things I've experienced in this podcast is helping people to see how psychology looks different these days. there is no one-size-fits-all. So I had a really lovely, powerful session with Sky, who's registered blind and has a guide dog.
这可能就是我生活的现实。我如何适应这种情况——适应那些不一定能轻易思考明白的事情？所以我想，当我们开始具备这种适应能力时，作为人类，我们所培养出的韧性中确实包含着某些东西。是的，绝对是这样。我认为我在这个播客中经历的非常美好的事情之一，就是帮助人们看到如今的心理学看起来有多么不同。这里没有所谓的“一刀切”。所以我与斯凯（Sky）进行了一次非常愉快、充满力量的交谈，她登记注册为盲人，并有一只导盲犬；
Yvonne, who uses a wheelchair, you know, a number of other people who just look different or may not look how you might expect as a psychologist or as an aspiring psychologist. And thank you for trusting the podcast to tell your story of looking different in psychology, but obviously still being able to really achieve. And I think what you're saying is you're able to form those meaningful working relationships that actually can be really beneficial.
还有使用轮椅的伊冯娜（Yvonne）；以及其他许多看起来不同，或者作为心理学家或有志成为心理学家的人，外表可能不像你所期望的那样的人。感谢你信任本播客，讲述你在心理学领域外表不同但依然能够真正取得成就的故事。我想你所表达的是，你能够建立那些真正有益的、有意义的工作关系。
Yeah, I really think actually there's something about how do we as human beings recognize that actually we're all trying to have some kind of experience. We might think that any profession, and that's not necessarily just psychology, we get caught up into some of these boxes of you must do this, this is quick and easy way. but actually what we end up being better clinicians by recognising, well, what is our lived experience? What is our human potential? And actually, how can this discipline really help me as well then to help others? You know, how do we use that lived experience to shape and help others? Because actually, you know, going back to compassion-focused therapy, we all experience suffering. I think there is something about how do we stop trying to switch off suffering,
是的，我真的认为，作为人类，我们该如何认识到，实际上我们都在努力获得某种体验。我们可能会认为任何职业——不一定仅仅是心理学——都会让我们陷入“你必须这样做，这是又快又容易的方法”这样的框框里，但实际上，我们通过认识到以下几点，最终会成为更好的临床医生：什么是我们的生活经验？什么是我们的潜能？实际上，这个学科又如何能真正帮助我，进而去帮助别人？你知道，我们如何利用这些生活经验来塑造和帮助他人？因为实际上，回到以同情为焦点的疗法，我们每个人都在经历痛苦。我认为有一点很重要，那就是我们如何停止试图关闭痛苦，
but really be able to expand in our own suffering in order to become free of it. And I think that for me has been particularly important, both not only from my therapy journey, but more recently my yogic journey as well. Yeah, isn't it just the best secret source that nobody necessarily talks about, that when you are progressing in a career in psychology, you get to learn the tips, the techniques, you get to actually feel better. I am so much more well as a person, as a mother, as a wife, as a daughter, as a friend. And I'm just better because I'm a clinical psychologist and because I'm surrounded by all of the people that are incredible around me. And when I am struggling,
而是真正能够在我们自己的痛苦中扩展开来，从而从中获得自由。我认为这对我来说特别重要，不仅从我的心理治疗之旅来看，而且从我最近的瑜伽之旅来看也是如此。是的，这难道不是每个人都不一定会谈论的最佳秘密武器吗？当你从事心理学职业并不断进步时，你会学到秘诀和技巧，你会真正感觉好多了。作为一个完整的人、一个母亲、一个妻子、一个女儿、一个朋友，我健康多了。我变得更好，因为我是一名临床医生，而且因为我周围环绕着所有这些了不起的人。当我陷入挣扎时，
I can reach out to people and be like, oh, I'm having a tricky time with this. And they're like, you know, firstly they might respond to me as a friend, but then they've also got the skills to be able to help me. And it's just the best. It's the best. Like if you're wondering about a career in psychology, you know, maybe think about adding that to your plus list, I would say. Yeah.
我可以向人们寻求帮助，说：“哦，我在这方面遇到了棘手的问题。”他们会说，你知道，首先他们会以朋友的身份回应我，但接着他们也具备了能够帮助我的技能。这真的是最棒的。这太棒了。如果你正在考虑从事心理学职业，你知道，也许可以考虑把这一点加到你的“加分项”列表里，我想我会这么说。是的。
And I guess for me, it's really important. You know, I guess as counselling psychologist, one of the things that was really important is to have your own therapy. because actually if you don't, it's hard to be aware of what your blind spots are. And I'm conscious not all part of applied psychology has their own therapy. But I think it's really important for us to recognise, well, actually this is what might be really challenging for me when I'm helping someone else.
对我来说，这非常重要。作为一名咨询心理学家，最重要的事情之一就是接受你自己的心理治疗。因为实际上，如果你不这样做，你就很难意识到自己的盲点在哪里。而且我意识到并不是所有应用心理学的分支都有自己的治疗要求。但我认为对我们来说，认识到这一点非常重要：实际上，当我在帮助别人时，这可能对我来说是非常具有挑战性的。
And especially, I guess, you know, working in forensic environments, we come across all sorts of things in terms of the dark nature of humanity. at the same time, we're human as well. And I think if you don't have the right skills to be able to process what might be going on, that's when we see all sorts of dynamics play out, whether that is at work or in the therapy room as well. And I think, you know, being on thinking about power as well, I think that's really important to recognise the power that you might hold without recognizing it as well. but also how do we, especially when we're thinking about being trauma informed, for example,
特别是，在法医环境中工作时，我们会遇到关于人性黑暗本质的各种各样的事情，但与此同时，我们也是人。我认为如果你没有合适的技能来处理可能发生的事情，那就会出现各种各样的动力学冲突，无论是在工作中还是在治疗室里。而且我认为，关于权力，我认为认识到你在不知不觉中可能掌握的权力也非常重要，
how do we recognise that actually once you start to sit with what you're suffering is, how do you empower yourself to free yourself from it? Because I guess it can be quite disempowering to get caught up in that loop of what are the areas that I don't want to go towards. Yeah, absolutely. Really important stuff. And I'm sort of thinking about, you know, when someone is pregnant, and Ormock gives birth and then experiences that moment where their child physically looks different
但同时我们该如何做，特别是在考虑具备创伤知情（trauma informed）意识时，我们如何认识到，一旦你开始直面你的痛苦，你该如何赋权自己从中解脱出来？因为我陷入那种不想面对的领域的循环中，可能会让人感到相当无力。是的，绝对是这样。非常重要的事情。我在想，当某个女性怀孕并分娩，然后经历那一刻，发现他们的孩子身体外表
than they expected. It's reminding me of when I worked in intellectual disability services and that's the idea of, well, you've packed for a holiday in the Caribbean, but then you realise that you've got to Italy and it's a city break and actually you feel like you're kind of woefully in-equipped and all the stuff that you brought with you, the tools, the skills, they aren't necessarily going to support you in this journey. How can we kind of, if we find ourselves working in services, supporting families, who are raising children, who might well be different than anyone in their family, different than what they
与他们预期不同时。这让我想起我曾在智力障碍服务机构工作的经历，这就好比：你打包准备去加勒比海度假，但后来你发现自己到了意大利，那是一场城市观光之旅，实际上你觉得自己的装备严重不足，你带的所有东西、工具、技能，不一定能支持你完成这段旅程。如果我们发现自己在各个机构工作，支持那些抚养孩子的家庭——这些孩子可能和他们家里的任何人都不一样，和他们预期的人不一样——我们该如何，我想，帮助他们看到这个孩子能够继续做成伟大的事情呢？正如你亲身证实的，你作为一名顾问和咨询心理学家，在非常高的水平上工作。但当然，这与别人可能预期的有所不同。
expected, how can we, I guess, help see, help them to see that this child can go on and do great things, you know, yourself evidenced, you are working at a very high level as a consultant and counselling psychologist. But of course, it is different than what somebody might have been expecting. Yeah, I think it's really important to think about, well, what support can we put into place? And I think support is really important. That empowers because I guess support, there's a tricky balance of what creates dependency and what empowers. And yeah, I think there's something of,
是的，我认为思考我们可以提供什么支持非常重要，支持真的很重要。这种支持要能赋权，因为支持有一点很难平衡，那就是什么会产生依赖，什么会赋权。是的，我觉得，
something about how do you use that as an opportunity to allow someone to flourish? You know, what do they need? Sometimes we might think we might know best, but that might not be the case. And I think, you know, I guess I feel very lucky in terms of the support that I had from my parents, from my extended family, from friends growing up. Yeah, I think there was always an opportunity, but also at the same time not to get stuck in it. Because I guess there's something, one of the things I try to work with clinically is thinking about the drama triangle, where actually we might really sit in that victim position where we feel hopeless and powerless all the time.
如何利用这一点作为一个契机，让一个人得以蓬勃发展？他们需要什么？有时我们可能认为我们最清楚，但事实可能并非如此。而且，我觉得自己在父母、大家庭、成长过程中的朋友所给予的支持方面非常幸运。是的，总是有机会的，但与此同时又不要陷在里面。因为我在临床上尝试处理的一件事，就是思考戏剧三角（drama triangle），我们在其中可能真的陷入受害者的位置，总是感到绝望和无力。
And I think that can lead us to feel quite dependent then on the system or become dependent on the system. And, you know, I recognise saying this, everyone's journey is going to be really individual. But I'm not saying that they don't need support. But I think there's a tricky, a slippery path in a way which could happen. And everyone's journey is going to be unique, but I think it is about what support is empowering rather than fostering dependence. Yeah. For anyone who's not familiar with the points on the drama triangle, could you briefly take us
我认为这会导致我们对体制产生依赖，或者变得对体制产生依赖。我意识到说这话时，每个人的旅程都是非常个体的。我并不是说他们不需要支持。但我认为这是一条微妙的、可能会滑向歧途的道路，每个人的旅程都是独一无二的，但关键在于什么样的支持才是赋权的，而不是助长依赖的。对于任何不熟悉戏剧三角中各个点的人，孙尼尔，你能给我们简要介绍一下那是什么吗？
through what that is, Sunil? Yeah, sure. So the drama triangle, kind of, we've got three points on it. So we've got victim, rescuer and perpetrator. And that's not necessarily about individual people. That could be systems, for example. And we often see this triangle play out, whether that's in services between people or between teams, for example,
好的，没问题。所以戏剧三角有三个顶点。我们有：受害者（victim）、拯救者（rescuer）和加害者（perpetrator）。这不一定是指具体的个人。例如，这也可以是体制。我们经常看到这个三角关系上演，无论是在服务中的人与人之间，还是在团队与团队之间，
where, you know, someone sits as a victim and, you know, because of experiencing some negative experiences. And then what often happens is that people might go into a rescuer position. And I think it's often that rescuer position which make people feel quite good. And therefore, there's always a trap, especially in the helping professions like psychology, where we could become the rescuer for someone. Or then when we might be put in boundaries or saying no, that's when people might be experiencing that individual as a perpetrator, for example, seeing a level of hostility, for example.
比如，某人因为经历了一些负面体验而扮演受害者的角色。然后经常发生的情况是，人们可能会进入拯救者的位置。而且我认为往往是那个拯救者的位置让人感觉相当好。因此，这里总是存在一个陷阱，尤其是在像心理学这样旨在助人的职业中，我们很容易成为某人的拯救者。或者当我们设立界限或说“不”时，人们就会把那个个体视为加害者，例如，表现出一定程度的敌意。
So I think what I've been trying to think about is how do we step out of this drama triangle by really challenging, by really empowering and encouraging and coaching people rather than getting stuck because also the positions might also move from person to person as well in this triangle. Thank you. Before we finish today, there might be someone listening to or watching this episode who maybe does feel a little bit different than their peers and wanting to it. to pursue a psychology or mental health career or maybe some other career and I just stumbled across us. What kind of advice or support would you offer, wise wisdom, would you offer to them? So I think there's something about how do you use your experiences as a vehicle to be able
所以我一直在思考的是，我们如何通过真正的挑战、真正的赋权、鼓励和指导人们来走出这个戏剧三角，而不是陷在其中，因为在这个三角中，角色也可能会在人与人之间转换。谢谢。在今天结束之前，可能有人正在收听或观看这一集，他们觉得自己可能和同龄人有点不同，想要追求心理学或心理健康职业，或者其他什么职业，而只是偶然发现了我们。你会对他们提供什么样的建议、支持或充满智慧的见解呢？所以我觉得，关键在于你如何将自己的经历作为帮助他人的工具？当然，首先思考这一点很重要：你如何先帮助自己？在你帮助别人之前，如何先给自己戴上氧气面罩？也许，
to help others? Obviously, it's important to think about firstly, how do you help yourself, you know, how do you put your oxygen mask on first before you help others? But maybe, you know, know, what do you need to learn about yourself to have the skills to really be able to understand suffering, for example, and how then that might be able to help others in your own journey and to really empower, but also be that positive vision. Because often we see, if we think about inspirations, we often see a certain type of person, for example, in leadership. position. So I think there is something about how how people could think about really leading with a different face, with a different body, with a different, any difference, for example, that we don't regularly see. Absolutely, because you are a leader and this is what drew me to you on LinkedIn. I think when we connected, I didn't even realise you're growing up in a
你需要了解关于自己的什么，才能具备真正理解痛苦的技能，以及这些技能如何在你的旅程中帮助他人并真正赋权，同时成为一个积极的愿景。因为通常如果我们想想灵感来源，我们经常会看到某种特定类型的人处于领导地位。所以我想，关键在于人们如何考虑以不同的面孔、不同的身体、不同的任何差异来真正发挥领导作用，而这些是我们平时不常看到的。绝对是这样，因为你是一位领导者，这正是我在领英上被你吸引的原因。我想当我们建立联系时，我甚至没有意识到你是在一个与众不同的身体里长大的，直到我们交谈时你说：“其实我也可以就这一点发表很多看法。”你能跟我们讲讲你的领导工作以及你在 NHS（英国国民医疗服务体系）所做的事情吗？
different body until we were speaking and you were like, actually I could really talk to this point as well. Could you tell us a little bit about your leadership, about what you're doing in the NHS? Yeah, sure. So like I said, I've got two different positions in the NHS. So currently I work in Northamptonshire for their Healthcare Foundation Trust. And so I lead a number of services in terms of psychology within their prison services, but also other specialist service. Also, just a range of prison services, including a low secure forensic ward and just other types of criminal justice services. So that kind of leadership is really important for me to support people to recognise the challenges that we face.
好的，没问题。就像我说的，我在 NHS 有两个不同的职位。目前我在北安普顿郡（Northamptonshire）的医疗保健基金会信托（Healthcare Foundation Trust）工作。我领导着他们监狱服务内部的心理学服务部门，以及其他一些专业服务。此外，还包括一系列监狱服务，包括一个低安全级别的法庭法医病房以及其他类型的刑事司法服务。因此，这种领导力对于我支持人们认识到我们所面临的挑战非常重要。
So, you know, doing reflective practice and training and recognising, again, the dark side of humanity. But also, I've got a national role as well. So I'm the National Clinical Director for Health and Justice in NHS England as well. So I provide a clinical view supported by various colleagues to make sure thinking about health and justice commissioning across the country, really, having that clinical viewpoint. Gosh, what a busy and demanding life. You've got, juggling it alongside your own life and family life as well. Wow, hats off to you.
所以，进行反思性实践和培训，并再次认识到人性的黑暗面。同时，我也扮演着国家级的角色。我是英格兰 NHS 健康与司法领域的国家临床主任。因此，在各种同事的支持下，我从临床的角度出发，确保在全国范围内考虑健康与司法方面的委任工作，真正具备这种临床视角。天哪，多么忙碌和充满需求的生活啊！你不仅要应对这一切，还要兼顾自己的生活和家庭生活。哇，向你致敬！
Thank you so much for your time and speaking with us. Where's the best place for people to learn more about you should they want to, Sunil? So I've done a TED talk a few years ago, which is on YouTube, just a 10-minute yoga practice where I briefly talk about my experience of yoga, being in a different body. There's another couple of podcasts out there as well. So any aspiring psychologists also, within NHFT we sometimes have positions available, especially for assistant psychologists or even qualified psychologists.
非常感谢你抽出时间与我们交谈。孙尼尔，如果人们想更多地了解你，哪里是最好的地方？几年前我做过一次TED演讲，在 YouTube 上可以找到，那是一个10分钟的瑜伽练习，我在其中简短地谈到了我练习瑜伽、身处不同身体的经历。还有其他几个播客节目。因此，对于任何有志成为心理学家的人，在 NHFT（北安普顿郡医疗保健基金会信托），我们有时也会提供职位空缺，特别是针对助理心理学家甚至是合格的心理学家。
So if anyone is interested, then they're more than welcome to get in touch. Perfect. Is LinkedIn the best place for people to follow you if they want to? Yes. Yeah, no definitely. I will make sure all those details are in the show notes and on screen. Thank you so much for your time. And if people, people are interested in hearing more about embodied practice and yoga, then that will be the topic of our next episode. Thank you so much, Sunil. Thank you. What an absolute pleasure to speak with Dr. Sunil Lad. If you enjoyed this conversation, I think you'll enjoy the next one too, because I am joined by Dr Sunil Lad again, and we're talking about embodied practice, which is a
所以如果有任何人感兴趣，非常欢迎与我取得联系。完美。如果人们想关注你，领英是最好的地方吗？是的。是的，绝对是。我会确保所有这些详细信息都写在节目简介（show notes）中以及屏幕上。非常感谢你抽出时间。如果人们有兴趣听到更多关于具身实践（embodied practice）和瑜伽的内容，那将是我们下一集的主题。非常感谢你，孙尼尔。谢谢。能与孙尼尔·拉德博士交谈真是莫大的荣幸。如果你喜欢这次对话，我想你也会喜欢下一次的对话，因为我又一次邀请到了孙尼尔·拉德博士，我们正在讨论具身实践，这是
wonderful episode, I know, because I've already recorded it at the point that I'm doing this outro for you. I hope you love being part of my world. I hope you love hearing stories about psychologists of different shapes, sizes, nationalities, backgrounds and experiences. If you do, I do think you'll really like the aspiring psychologist collective book and the clinical psychologist collective book, which both get excellent reviews and gives you a really lovely insight into the world of psychologists and what got them to be where they are. I would also love it if you consider writing a blog article for the aspiring psychologist. Why not check out the ones we've already got?
一个美妙的节目，我知道，因为在我为你录制这段片尾时，我已经把它录好了。我希望你喜欢成为我世界的一部分。我希望你喜欢听到关于不同形状、大小、国籍、背景和经历的心理学家的故事。如果你喜欢，我想你真的会喜欢《有志心理学家合集》（the aspiring psychologist collective book）和《临床心理学家合集》（the clinical psychologist collective book）这两本书，它们都获得了极佳的评价，能让你对心理学家的世界以及是什么让他们走到今天有非常美好的了解。如果你考虑为《有志心理学家》撰写一篇博客文章，我也会很高兴。为什么不看看我们已经发表的文章呢？
Head along to www. aspiring hyphen psychologist.co.com. UK and then scroll to the free resources tab and then click on blog. I might well try and make that a bit simpler and try and add blog to the main screen too. And whilst you are there, why not check out the aspiring psychologist membership too? I think you might enjoy that as well. If you'd like to consider joining my inner work, the backstage crew, you can join the channel for exclusive members-only content.
访问 www.aspiringhyphenpsychologist.co.uk，然后滚动到“免费资源”（free resources）标签页，点击“博客”（blog）。我可能会试着把它弄得更简单一点，也把博客添加到主屏幕上。当你浏览到那里时，为什么不顺便看看“有志心理学家会员”（the aspiring psychologist membership）呢？我想你也会喜欢的。如果你想考虑加入我的内部工作坊——幕后工作人员，你可以加入该频道以获取专属的仅限会员观看的内容。
They're really lovely little standalone episodes that help you think about where you are at right now. There's details in the show notes or in the description. With this podcast, that's your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the aspiring psychologist podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这些是非常可爱的独立小节目，能帮助你思考你目前所处的位置。节目简介或描述中有详细信息。有了这个播客在你的身边，你将迈向成为合格心理学家的道路。这就是由玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）主持的《有志心理学家播客》。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。